Representative keith Keith Self is a Republican.
He represents the area that suffered this
terrible, terrible shooting. Alan, Texas. And he
was actually asked on CNN, what about all these
people who just say thoughts and prayers? That
doesn't work. And he said, oh, yeah, it does. You
just have to believe in the power of God. What?
Explain that to me, Keith. Listen to this. Now,
you know, Congressman, that is a common refrain
after these incidents, after mass shootings. But
many people argue that prayers aren't cutting
it. Prayers are not preventing the next mass
shooting. I wish she said she said, rather than
many people argue. Just prayer is don't prevent
mass shootings. And you say many people argue.
It's like, well, but many people argue that they
do. No, it's just prayers don't prevent mass
shootings, and yet it's all you're willing to
offer. Listen to this. What is your response to
that criticism? Well, those are people that don't
believe in an almighty God who who has
who is absolutely in control of our
lives. I'm a Christian. I believe that he is.
Oh, we have people, though, with mental health
that we're not taking care of. Oh, this nation
made the decision that we were going to close
the mental health institutions. Many of these
situations are based on that. And the people
that say and I really I would like to stay away
from the politics today because I want to focus
on the victims. Right. Except the problem is
right wingers who want to do nothing. Always
want to stay away from the politics. They are the
political problem. Right. It's it's it's almost a
sick joke to say, listen, this is not about guns.
This is about we need mental institutions, which
were horrifying, by the way. Many of the ones
that closed were horrifying. I've been reading
a book about it. In fact, worst conditions.
Nobody's getting cured at those places.
And but but prayer works. But let's not, like,
get all political. I want to take the politics
out of it. We could take the politics out of it if
we just did what the American people agreed should
be done. Five of the ten or 12 things that I've
outlined before he makes the political issue are a
necessity because he and many of his party say we
don't need anything other than prayer. And I guess
mental institutions today we should be focused on
the families. Oh, prayer is powerful in the lives
of those people that are devastated. I know
people says who want to make this political,
but prayers are important and they are powerful
in the families who are devastated right
now. That may or may not be. It is completely
compatible to say prayer may be a soothing tool
for victims or it may not. It's up to them. But it
has nothing to do with what civil government must
do about this scourge or scourge of gun violence,
depending on whose pronunciation you prefer.
These can be two different things, but prayer from
elected officials certainly can't be considered
policy. Remember when a few weeks ago people
were furious with me because I said, Hey guys,
if you need any more evidence that prayer doesn't
work, it's that people were shot up at a Christian
school where they presumably pray all the
time. And people were remind me, Oh, David,
that's so insensitive, you Christian hating Jew
bastard. We've got a lot of those. How dare you
blame the kids, folks. The prayer doesn't work.
That's the problem. Whoever thought it did, they
were wrong. It's not the kids. This is really the
offensive thing to say. You've just got to believe
in an almighty God who controls everything. And
think of that if you truly and literally believe.
That a God is in charge of the minutia of
everything, including mass shootings. Why would
you legislate anything? And that's the danger that
you have to really understand. If we believe Keith
Selfe is literally representing his views now, the
prayer is what we need because God is in control
of everything. Then, of course, they're not going
to do anything legislatively. They don't think
they have to because God has already decided
how many shootings there are or aren't going
to be and who's going to survive or die. It's
a copout to do nothing, which is exactly what
they've done. So that works really well for them.
The David Pacman Show continues to be an audience
funded program may be different than some of the
shows you're used to watching. We don't have a
big corporate funder. We don't have a massive ad
budget. What we have are people who listen to the
show or watch the show and like it enough to say,
Hey, I'm going to contribute a few bucks a month.
That's really all we're talking about. We
provide great perks with great strength,
including the award winning bonus show. It is
true. It's all awards we've given out. But still,
I do think we should consider them valuable. You
also get commercial free audio and video streams
of the show every single day. You get invited
to the members only town halls. We've got a
soundboard that you can use That is a frickin
predator right there. Yes. On the member side
of the website, there's a soundboard you can
use for whatever reasons you might want to use
it. I'm not going to give anybody any ideas. And
you can sign up at join Pacman dot com. Always.
There is a coupon code available this week. You
can use the coupon code. Indicted. Indicted.